- All right, everybody.
We are back and I'm here
with Taylor Thomason,
give it up.
(crowd cheering)
(crowd clapping)
At just 12 and nine, our
next guests know exactly
what they want to do for
the rest of their lives:
make music and do good for others.
They're actually already doing it y'all,
they have their own band.
Their very own band, play
gigs around Los Angeles
and every dollar that they earn,
they give back to important
causes and people in need.
From First Day of School.
(crowd cheering)
Let's say hi to brothers
Bradley and Bowie.
(crowd cheering)
(both cheering)
Y'all are so young to be doing,
I was just telling
Taylor in the coursework,
I was like, I don't know
if I was helping people at nine and 12.
I was like, I was not a
good kid or something.
I don't even know I knew
like to do that's so cool.
But meet Taylor.
- Hi.
- Hi, nice to meet you guys.
- Nice to meet you too.
- I didn't get the memo,
the light up shoes.
- Oh! Thank you!
- Those are so cool!
- They're so rad.
I know I was, I'm old.
The only shoes that
lit up when I was a kid
were when you had to bounce on 'em.
- Oh yeah!
- You had to like walk.
- Oh yeah.
- I love those.
- I love those kind of shoes.
- I know they're more progressive now.
Fine. So the band is
called First Day of School.
So tell us more about
how it all got started
and where y'all play.
- We grew up in a musical family
and my mom is a singer songwriter.
My dad loves musicals.
- Oh, awesome.
- I guess music's just in her blood.
- I love it.
I love- aw y'all are so cute.
- Aw.
- So what do you play?
- Well, I play piano.
I've been playing piano since COVID hit
and my brother has been playing guitar
since he was about seven.
Yeah.
- Wow, right on
and 12 that's five years.
You have like regular gigs, right?
- Yes, every Sunday on the
third street promenade,
we play most types of genres
but we mostly play oldies, Elvis.
- Love.
- Rock and pop.
- And sometimes some Kelly Clarkson.
- Okay, so you have classics in there.
Yeah. Yeah.
So wait, you use all your tips, right?
And you give them to people right?
- Yes.
- Yes, we're doing this special thing
called the decade set list.
- Yeah.
- Where we start for the 1950s.
And we go all the way
to the 2020s and we play
about one to two songs every
decade, depending on the-
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah, depending on the crowd
you're even knowing your audience.
at such a young age.
I like it.
- We usually get
about $150 to $300 every
single time we play out.
- Wow.
- So, we donate up
like all of our money to-
- Yeah.
- Our organizations
that we pick each month.
We have donated to Toys for Tots.
- Yeah.
- Organization Heal the Bay and Team Seas.
which is an awesome organization
which removed 30 million
pounds of trash out of our-
- Oh my gosh.
- Ocean.
- How important it is that yeah.
- Yeah, and all the money
that we have donated
to various organization is about $15,000.
- Oh my gosh. Look at you
doing at such a young age.
I'm telling you,
I mean I could tell a girl scout cookie
that's about all I could do at your age.
I didn't do any of that.
So what artists have
influenced you in your music?
- Well, we like tons of different bands
but we really like boy bands right now.
- [Kelly] Oh yeah.
Oh I love it!
- Especially like One Direction
and the Back Street Boys.
- Yeah.
- Yeah!
- Yes!
- It's because they are so awesome.
They like do it all. They sing
and dance at the same time.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Which is awesome!
- [Kelly] Write music. Yeah they do.
- And it's really important to us because
we are both dancers.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- Yeah.
- Okay. Well, I can't wait for that video.
Okay, so I know some musicians
who are super inspired by
Bradley and Bowie's drive
and how they're passionate
and they're helping others.
And this is something
that they're really into.
So do you mind if we bring them out?
- Sure!
- Okay.
Well maybe we'll just say hello to Kevin,
Brian, Howie, Nick and AJ
of the Backstreet Boys.
- What!
(crowd cheering)
(upbeat music)
- What's up boys?
- Hey!
- How's it going man?
- How are you guys doing?
- My goodness!
- Hey buddy!
- How are you?
- How are you doing?
- Hi.
- Look at you!
- Good job.
(crowd cheering)
- He said What!
- He's the business man right here.
- What!
- Good job!
- Oh my God!
- Little business man!
- Good Job!
- Yo, come on over here.
Wait, so what do you wanna say
to Bradley and Bowie guys?
Were y'all doing this
kind of stuff at this age.
I'm just like what?
- No.
- Not this guy.
- No, not at his age.
- No, a couple years later.
- Well, let me just say first
off you guys are awesome.
Okay.
(crowd cheering)
- Yes, yeah.
- Second.
Secondly, we'd like to invite you
to our Irvine California Show.
If you want to come be our guests.
Wanna come?
- Yes!
- What! Are you.
- That cool?
- Oh my goodness! Thank you!
- Now, wait, there's more
there's more, okay?
- There's more!
- Thirdly, you guys have
inspired us so much,
we wanna donate $25,000
to your three favorite charities.
- I believe it's Toys for Tots,
it's Team Seas and Heal the Bay.
- Yeah.
- Cool?
- Thank you!
- Congratulations!
- Look what y'all did!
You got all these people help
because of your love for them!
(crowd cheering)
- Oh, I don't know.
- Thank you so much!
- You're welcome.
- Oh, this is so beautiful!
That was so exciting. I will
never forget your "What!"